. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE AND WELCOME BACK. THE
SENATE HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE
A HEARING IS. GONNA GET ROLAND
SO. WE WANT TO GO AHEAD AND
ESTABLISH QUORUM SO SENATOR CAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. RICARDO.
RICARDO HERE STONE BELL JACKSON
JACKSON HERE PAN PAN HERE
WINNER FOR THE WINNER HERE. WE
HAVE ESTABLISHED WARM WITH FOR
MEMBERS PRESENT. AND NOW WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND WAIT FOR THE
AUTHOR
. I KIND OF INVITED
MYSELF. OKAY. ONE THIRTY.
WELCOME SENATOR RUBIO AND
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
YOUR BILL WHENEVER YOU ARE
READY. THANK YOU I GET MORNING
MEMBERS AND SHARE A TODAY I'M
PRESENTING SB SIX EIGHTY SEVEN
A BILL TO INCREASE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE STATE'S
EFFORTS TO ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S
HOMELESS CRISIS. BY ADDING A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM TO THE
HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCIAL COUNCIL ONE OF THE
LARGEST SEGMENTS OF THE STATE'S
HOMELESS POPULATION IS HOMELESS
COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY
STUDENTS. EIGHT TWENTY NINETEEN
REPORT BY THE HOPE CENTER FOR
COLLEGE COMMUNITY AND JUSTICE
FOUND THAT 90% OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
FACE THE CHALLENGE OF BEING
HOMELESS IN THE PAST YEAR.
OTHER RECENT STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
THAT NEARLY 11% OF CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY STUDENTS AND
5% OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS HAVE
REPORTED INCIDENTS OF BEING
HOMELESS. THROUGH CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN
THE BUSINESS AND CONSUMER
SERVICES AND HOUSING AGENCY I
HAVE AMENDED THE BILL TO ENSURE
ATTENTION IS FOCUSED ON THE
UNIQUE CHALLENGES FACED BY
THOSE HOMELESS STUDENTS WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIVAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DO WE HAVE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. DO WE
HAVE ANYONE THAT WANTS TO SPEAK
AGAINST THIS BILL IN OPPOSITION
WITH THE BILL. OKAY ANY
COMMENTS FROM OF COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. OKAY SO. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THE DEAL THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
OKAY SENATOR PLEASE CALL. ALL
OF THEM ARE FAR WE HAVEN'T SO
THAT THEY'RE THE MOST WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE ON THE FLOOR AND
THE MOTION IS TO. THE SUB. AREA.
OKAY THAT THE SIMPLY AMENDMENTS
COULD CONCURRED AND SELF
SECRETARY PLEASE HOLD OFF
RICARDO. HER DAUGHTER I STONE
STONE HI BILL JACKSON JACKSON
AYE PAN PAN AYE WIENER. WIENER
AYE. OKAY THE BILL IS FIVE ZERO
IN THAT BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO